au dessus de la vallée de katmandou au
népal le monastère de doro camille tabac
tous les matins ce bouddha au visage
impassible est témoin d'un cérémonial
inattendue
ces jeunes qui s'entraînent au congrès
sont en réalité vous donne
un coup de genou et à coups de pied elle
renverse le rugby sme tradition
[Musique]
dans les autres monastères les noms
n'ont pas le droit de pratiquer d'arts
martiaux
que le monde entier sache ce qu'on fait
ici l'enseignement féministe qu'on
reçoit ça a vraiment changé ma vie
la pratique du kung fu nous renforce
physiquement et mentalement et nous
donne de la confiance
historiquement dans la religion
bouddhiste lennon sont considérées comme
inférieures aux moines
interdiction pourrait d'accéder à des
échelons supérieurs encore moins de
pratique
[Musique]
mais cet homme a tout changé quoi
londres ou pas et le chef spirituel
d'une branche dispo tibétains vieille
demi siècle
il ya 25 ans à sainté a décidé de
chambouler le système patriarcal avec un
nouveau credo girl power
les gens ont toujours pensé que les
femmes ne pouvaient pas atteindre
l'illumination
qu'elle ne pouvait pas participer à
certains rites et qu'elles étaient
bonnes qu'à faire la cuisine
moi je veux unifier une révolution
un changement de mentalités pour que les
femmes puissent jouer un rôle dans le
monde
voilà donc pas ouvert de couvent qui
attire de plus en plus de jeunes filles
venues suivre une règle de vie austère
et révolutionnaire
[Musique]
3 heures du matin la journée commence
tôt coupant les plus jeunes soeurs
vivent dans ce dortoir très peu de place
pour des affaires personnelles
[Musique]
yang sheng hameau est arrivé ici il ya
six ans la jeune fille provient d'une
vallée éloignée du népal
[Musique]
quand je vivais au village mes parents
de répéter qu'un jour j'allais devoir me
marier arrêté les études quand
j'entendais ça ça me faisait peur
j'adorais les études je travaillais dur
il aurait fallu que j'abandonne tout
pour me retirer dans la maison de mon
mari et puis je suis devenu nonnes et
tout a changé ici je me sens ainsi forte
que les garçons et je peux faire ce que
je veux
ce matin yang chen se lance dans une
forme spéciale de méditation très
physique
lennon doivent ainsi se prosterner 4000
fois par semaine
c'est pas facile de faire ses exercices
ça demande un grand effort physique
il faut les répéter beaucoup entre 500
et mille fois la suite
je fais ça pour atteindre l'illumination
c'est prosternation me permettent
d'exprimer péché de purifier mon corps
et mon âme
après la méditation l'école qui a lieu
sous cette tente
les soeurs apprennent le tibétain la
langue sacrée mais aussi l'anglais elles
reçoivent des cours de philosophie elise
des écrits sacrés autant d'enseignements
auparavant interdit aux femmes
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
atteindre l'éternité
par l'illumination
la professeure est aussi le bras droit
du chef spirituel
j'ai vu tellement de vienne comme des
esclaves
elles n'ont jamais reçu d'enseignement
sa sainteté nous a donné le pouvoir de
surmonter tous ces obstacles
ce qu'on a mis en place ici scandalise
les gens vous savez nous sommes les
premières à faire tout ça à promouvoir
une véritable égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes
[Musique]
depuis que le prince idar tas a fondé le
bouddhisme il ya 2600 ans c'est la
première fois que des femmes dirige la
prière
[Musique]
pas de dîner au couvent seulement deux
repas par jour spartiate sans doute mais
la plupart de ces jeunes filles
proviennent de familles pauvres
telle chaîne n'a que 10 ans c'est la
plus jeune soeur du couvent
ce matin elle s'entraîne sous la
direction de yangshe
attention à tes pieds
tiens-toi droite
fléchi bien les jambes
la petite fille est arrivée d'inde il y
a trois mois
elle n'est autorisé à appeler ses
parents que quelques fois par mois
[Musique]
bonjour maman comment ça va
moi ça va bien
détienne veut rassurer sa maman sur son
état de santé je suis tombé malade
pendant quelques jours
mais je vais mieux
c'est à cannes bat je peux voir un
docteur et si ce besoin
elle m'a dit que
je lui ai beaucoup manqué
la petite fille n'a le droit de rentrer
dans sa famille qu'une fois tous les
quatre ans ses parents pourraient lui
rendre visite mais ils n'ont pas assez
d'argent pour faire le déplacement
[Musique]
détiennent s'est décidé à prendre
l'habit après avoir vu des nonnes
traversé son visage
j'ai été impressionné quand je les ai
vus arriver sur leur vélo
leur façon d'être la nourriture qu'elle
mangeait tout ça m'a donné envie de
venir ici
et la pratique du concours bien sûr
qui me rend si heureuse
chaque année une délégation de nonnes
parcours l'himalaya à pied ou à vélo
[Musique]
ces derniers mois elles ont traversé
l'inde a dit cycle est et troquer la
rode pour le maillot de cycliste
[Musique]
nous voulons parcourir plus de 2000
kilomètres pendant 72 jours
depuis katmandou jusqu en inde
pour attirer l'attention sur la
sauvegarde de l'environnement
le périple a également servi à lever des
fonds pour la reconstruction du népal
après le séisme d'avril 2015 qui avait
fait huit mille morts
le couvent de drew camille tabac a été
sévèrement endommagées sans faire
deviner heureusement
même finir l'entraînement du kung fu
certaines sont sortis par la fenêtre et
d'autres sont passés par là on voulait
sortir par la porte mais en fait il n'y
en avait plus seulement un grand trou
dans le mur
kenchop 23 ans et l'électricien du
couvent
pas toi les outils s'il te plaît ce
besoin de fils électriques et d'une
perceuse et tout ça à la barre
cet après-midi mission raccordement
électrique
[Musique]
on me demande parfois si j'ai un diplôme
d'ingénieur
mais non pas du tout en fait on a dû
tout appris ici
j'ai vu la discrimination à l'oeuvre
dans mon village
et je veux que notre travail c'est un
exemple pour montrer que les femmes
peuvent tout faire autant que les hommes
[Musique]
le travail communautaire l'ail ou six
jours sur sept
le dimanche c'est jour de repos
une attaque
discussions entre filles autour d'une
tasse de thé
[Musique]
il ya quand même quelques obligations
les cibles hebdomadaire et séance de
rasage obligatoire
donc chaîne se chargent des cheveux de
compte chaque
tu te sens comment super
on tient tout à nos cheveux donc c'est
un symbole de notre attachement de la
zone
quand j'étais jeune j'adorais prendre
soin de mes longs cheveux ça a été très
dur des rased
le soir session cinéma
un rare moment de distraction
on ne regarde pas de films romantiques
on choisit souvent des films d'arts
martiaux ou des films créatifs
où l'on apprend quelque chose
surtout des films d'arts martiaux ou des
films d'horreur et pourquoi pas de films
romantiques
parce qu'ils
ne sont pas bien
ça va commencer
le film va commencer
à l'écran un célèbre panda
qui triomphe de saisine
on se défausse
[Musique]
quelques heures plus tôt les petites
planètes assister un rituel
exceptionnelle la danse du tarn à la
cérémonial auparavant réservé aux hommes
les petites soeurs ne sont que quelques
centaines
pourquoi avec élégance elle prise peu à
peu le plafond de verre du bouddhisme
tibétain
quelques pas de camp ce bien légal comme
ça